el petrolero en inmersión street se
encontraba en el norte del océano índico
frente a la costa de omán dirigiéndose
desde tanzania a los emiratos árabes
unidos- cuando se produjo el ataque el
buque está gestionado por la empresa
londinense zodiac marítima propiedad de
una de las personas más ricas del mundo
el multimillonario israelí de ofer
zodiac marítima emitió un comunicado con
profunda tristeza informamos de que el
incidente a bordo del gen timer ser
street del 29 de julio de 2021 ha
provocado la muerte de dos miembros de
la tripulación un ciudadano rumano y
otro británico israel señala con el dedo
a irán y promete una dura respuesta el
ministro de asuntos exteriores israelí
yair lapid dijo que el mundo no puede
permanecer en silencio ante el terror
iraní
el canal de televisión estatal iraní al
alam cito fuentes que decían que el
ataque era una respuesta al reciente
ataque de israel la de aeropuerto de
daba en siria expertos en explosivos de
la marina de eeuu volaron el viernes
para apoyar a la tripulación del
petrolero el incidente es el primer
ataque mortal conocido tras años de
agresiones en la región el analista de
industria marítima dryad global afirma
que se trata del quinto ataque contra un
barco vinculado a israel anteriormente
ha habido una serie de ataques a buques
operados tanto por israel como por iran
en lo que parece ser una guerra en la
sombra no declarada entre ambos países